[Music]
no your eyes aren't deceiving you I am
on the set of American Ninja Warrior
celebs are gearing up to run the course
in honor of Red Nose Day and guess what
so my my only goal not to get my hair
way
this course is huge you're about to do
it I'm about to do it how are you
feeling I mean Derek Hough who I was on
Dancing the Stars with a few years ago
did it last year and I remember watching
those like this looks like so much fun
to me like it's all upper body strength
and I'm like awesome I have none of that
now we're screwed
any advice for me I'm yeah this is the
first time I'm stepping onto the course
like I haven't even warmed up yet on the
little balls that rotate you have to go
super fast like if you stop they like
spin back and forth so you just have to
like go on bless you for thinking I was
gonna get that far I think the best
piece of advice would be to just attack
everything even if you're scared
pretend you're confident and just go for
it because the minute you hesitate
that's when things go south you know
what pretending to be confident I've
been doing that my whole life Megan OH
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
focus buddy you got this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
not bad though that I got to tell you my
goal was snagging my hair away I failed
there but I meted to the balls giving
you advice what I'd love is you took the
advice I saw your confidence growing
with every step I think if you had a
little bit more training getting you
could be the real deal
so today unite we have this thing in
common we've never been on a ninja
warrior course before and we're stepping
out in front of thousands of people
millions of people watching at home it
takes some courage to do that it's a lot
easier to be in the host and hold it
holding the mic and not trying divorce
you hear that hear that you know what it
is here's what it is we're both doing
our part for the children in Red Nose
Day and that's what's really important
it's not who's out there getting the
credit or who's out there making fun of
them what's important is we help the
children on Red Nose Day for sure I mean
what piece of advice you have for him
now they didn't run this course this guy
is a specimen but he's the wrong body
type for this but his athletic mindset
he's a killer you know it's funny
because when I when I played in the NFL
they used to call me BMW and it wasn't
because I was a fine automobile they
used to call me body made wrong and that
definitely applies here body made wrong
for Ninja Warrior no what am i if your
BMW I'm a 95 Honda City okay
I'd like to thank Oprah I like to thank
Beyonce I really channeled her inner
fierceness that was my Sasha Fierce
moment I feel like a warrior
[Music]